I've been doing recruitment for six
years now and I remember when I went
into Recruitment and there was all these
people having success around me and it
just felt like it was never going to
come for me so
I don't want to talk crap on here and
say you're going to get it instantly if
you do all these things because it's a
slog
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Tisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Amy holder
obviously you started your recruitment
career at Austin Fraser in 2017. in that
first year you won 29 clients your
average deal size was between 8 to 12
Grand the second year you have goes to
hopefully break the 300 Grand Mark yes
who in the first couple of years of her
recruitment career found it tough until
over the last two years she's really
found our home but let's put yourself in
that client's shoes and they are
honestly getting hundreds of approaches
a day why are they going to open your
message why are they going to come back
to you recently winning the top
performer award at Adecco she's built
her Market entirely from scratch when
you are yourself those relationships
that you're going to build they're
authentic they're going to work with you
because they're you in this conversation
we cover everything from Market mapping
getting introductions to hiring managers
the Excel spreadsheet that Amy uses to
manage leads and we go into every single
detail what else have you done do you
think that's really impacted you having
repeat clients and repeat business I got
so many thoughts going through my head
at the moment and I think for any of you
that are in the process of building your
Market building your brand you're going
to absolutely love this episode enjoy
Amy welcome to the podcast hello
thanks for coming in obviously it's your
birthday tomorrow you're on annual leave
today
and you're you're with me in the podcast
Studio yeah the holidays it's
appreciated
um you're welcome obviously I've we've
had a few failed attempts where I've
been honest with you I've reached out
with not that much time and then you've
been like I can imagine you're like this
guy's just trying to get him in when
he's just got someone dropped out yeah I
was thinking that no no I know you're
busy as well so I was like well um so
yeah really excited to sit down with you
I think what what prompted me reaching
out to you was
it was pretty sure I'm pretty sure it
was when you posted the you won the plum
concern of the year
um and I think I've shared with you
right that when I saw that I was like
perfect right Amy would you ever be you
know um against common on the podcast
like no um would definitely be up for
that
um and always try and be proactive
because I find it harder to get women on
the podcast I just do so you know anyone
that is shouting about their
achievements and is female I'm like hey
do you want to come on the podcast let's
chat yeah let's chat right yeah
um so what we're going to do today just
to give people some immediate content so
you let me know if I get any of this
wrong but when we prepared for this
obviously you started your recruitment
career
Austin Fraser in 2017. and I think you
shared with me
um you know he was right quite honest
with me was like you know what in those
first three years I really found it
tough to like find you know my sweet
spot be as good as I am now and where
you've really found your your home is in
the last two years with Adecco
um and that's what we really wanted to
focus on today because you joined that
business and you were building a team
from scratch and I think a lot of people
have aspirations to do that build their
desk so we just really today wanted to
focus on how you've gone about that
um and the things that you've learned
right yeah so just to give people
context on that so for the last two
years so join The Deco September
um 2021 yeah at
um and you joined there to build out a
market from scratch which was in the
life science space
all perm all Pam yeah and obviously
previously you did contract yeah right
so all perm
um in your first year you did 255 and
you're now in the you know the thick of
your second year
in that first year you won 29 clients 22
of those clients you did more than one
placement with your average deal size
was between 8 to 12 Grand you've only
worked in the uh the UK Market with this
desk
um and you're halfway through you know
the second year you have goals to
hopefully break the 300 Grand Mark yes
and obviously those achievements there
was what enable you to get that
permanent of the year uh awarded right
yes is that across like the yeah a deco
split it's a huge business right there's
people all over but in terms of the
London team you've got a specialism
sector which involves life science I.T
lots of different people
um across the UK and Ireland as well
um but there's certain people that will
come into that category and then if
you've done great Billings or you might
have different categories such as like
pulled certain amount of clients but
mine was purely on billions so yeah it
was spread within a specialisms market
um in order to break it down so
otherwise you'd have too many people
going on like the end of year trip yeah
and that's what it was for so it was I
was buzzing like it was one first whole
year got on the trip which is always
like a massive goal right you want to go
out and enjoy yourself
um so yeah
um Athens in Greece nice yeah it rained
the whole time it was still great
um so let's start the million pound
question which I always like to start
with Amy's perspective on
characteristics and traits of a highly
successful recruit in today's market
okay I think the first thing I'll always
say is be yourself
um and I know that sounds so so simple
but it's something that loads of people
fail to do I failed to do and I started
in sales in working in the state agency
and then I moved into Recruitment and
Interstate agency I worked in Henley
which is like quite a well to do areas a
lot of Posh people there and I'm so far
from that but my boss was like right
when people come in you need to be like
yes sir Madam and it just it didn't work
like that's not who I am that's not how
I speak so I struggled with that and I
started to find my own in that but then
when I moved to recruitment it was the
same I was trying to put on this Persona
of oh I'm really I'm just started out
but I've got to be really good at my job
I've got to know everything and I didn't
and I was trying to put on this Persona
and it wasn't who I was and I was
speaking in a way that was probably a
little bit more like posher than I am as
well that people see right through it so
you've got to be yourself and it was
only when I started showing up as myself
that I made some really good connections
and relationships with clients because I
think when you are yourself those
relationships that you're going to build
they're authentic they're going to work
with you because they're you if they're
working with you and you're not yourself
those relationships aren't going to last
because at the end of the day you're not
going to meet on certain values and so
be yourself is the most important thing
people will work with you for you
I think as well you know you've probably
spoken with loads of recorders right
it's got still got a bad rep and it
needs to change in that people aren't
honest
um they're not feeding back then they
don't care maybe about people's
experience in the process and I see it
all the time on LinkedIn there's loads
of redundancies and people just aren't
hearing back from recruitous one of my
friends the other day he was in a
process and the recruiter said he called
him never called him he chased they
finally called him three times after
chase him for a job they said they put
him forward and then again never heard
back and it's like that's too common so
I think you just need to do what you say
you're going to do as a person so if you
say you're going to call someone at a
certain time call them at that time and
make sure they just have a good
experience so be honest be yourself have
a good experience with that person and
treat them how you want to be treated
and if you just do that it sounds super
simple but you'll probably be 100 better
than a lot of other people that are
doing that job because they'll be
missing out on those things
curious be yourself
did with your journey did that coincide
with Amy knowing who Amy was more yeah
for sure let as you get older right you
start to realize what you care about
what you don't care about and what all
the white noise is in the background and
I think when you're younger you want to
please so many people and there's a lot
of expectation a lot of pressure and you
don't know who you are as much but I'm
towards the end of my 20s now
come on yeah get in there
um not quite there's still things to
work on obviously but yeah I know I know
what I can handle more and I know who I
am way more than I was so that will
definitely come with time you'll just
you'll find your way
um and you've got to make mistakes to
get there as well yeah I just think it's
a good Insight like if because I do hear
that a lot and how much more fun work
would be if you feel like you can be
yourself and you know one of the ways
you can get there more quickly is trying
to you know work on understanding who
you are what's important to these things
so it's interesting that you said that
so let's just get straight into this
then so like what was the plan for
starting this uh market like what
because I think you said to me that the
first thing you did was you mapped the
market and this is quite a common
exercise that I think sometimes people
don't take it seriously or great
recruiters will make sure that they map
the market so talk talk us through your
business plan for you know starting this
desk from scratch
um how did you go about identifying the
right companies what made up from your
perspective the right companies let's
just sort of start there and we'll get
straight into it yeah okay so yeah map
in the market can mean so many different
things right and you're like well what
does that actually mean for me I've had
experience before where I've gone into a
business and it's already been mapped
but I found that really difficult
because there was so much data on there
that I didn't know what to do with it I
was in a really unique position that
I've gone into a clean database there's
pretty much no candidates there's no
clients so I've got everything to play
with from scratch that's super cool so
what I would do in order to map out the
market I need to find out who who hires
QA Specialists and how do they hire them
so to do that it would be speaking with
candidates and speaking with clients and
making every conversation as much as
you're helping them what do they want
out of looking for a job like where do
they want to work what are their drivers
you need to then position that to help
yourself so where do they work what's
their team size like how many people
have they hired or lost within that
period of Time how did they get that job
was that through an agency like ask the
questions and make it a really
well-rounded conversation so that you're
both getting something to support
yourself and you know you can help grow
your Market once you've had those
questions with candidates and clients
you'll start to see okay these people
have all hired been hired using an
agency what kind of agency are there are
are they life science specific or are
they really generalists because a lot of
the time I find if they are generalist
they struggle it's a long time to find
people just because they've got so many
different jobs they don't know those
Niche languages and the conversations to
have with the candidates
so I would say you need to map out that
way and you make a list of clients
equally another way that you can map it
not only having those conversations but
leads right so all the time you hear
about people I've got um an interview
here or I've been offered a job here but
I'm not taking it whatever you do with
that you might go and then try and Chase
that yourself that's brilliant but if
not I have this Excel spreadsheet where
I'm like okay this business have been
hiring loads and every time I get a lead
I write that lead down on my Excel
spreadsheet and then I organize that A
to Z and that will then populate so it
might be 10
um 10
lists of the company basically so it
might be the company 10 times and I'm
like oh they've went to hire 10 times
within the last year they're someone
that I want to go after whereas I might
have only got one lead for another
company and that might then equate to
they're actually not hiring that much so
they're not going to be a huge Target so
firstly you've got to understand that
and then once you've got that it's all
about the touch points so how frequently
are you contacting them and then what
approach does that look like so once you
know that agencies spend how often
they're hiring what the roles are that
they're hiring for it's then all about
the approach right okay let's let's
break this down so firstly we'd love to
know
what columns are in the spreadsheet yeah
okay do you know I just did a training
session on this yeah right so what is
this what are the columns in the
spreadsheet because every time we've
asked it's been a spreadsheet for people
what are the columns in your spreadsheet
I love a spreadsheet right we spend so
much money on CRM so then we've got this
this Excel spreadsheet that's all for me
right I've got loads of different
spreadsheets if we're looking at
um
I'm going to first talk about my client
spreadsheets I think that would help
people in mind so my columns are trying
to visualize it now I've got clients
with terms of business agreed yeah
anybody that I have agreed times with
they are in that column they're in that
list because then I will contact them
they're in my diary they're Diaries in
my calendar every six weeks I'll spend a
whole week going through and retouching
but touching base again I hate that word
touch and bass I'm not going to use that
again
but getting in touch with those clients
to keep those relationships alike so
that's my terms of business agreed I've
then got attraction Client List keep in
touch so if I've ever sent a mail shot
or anyone's ever come back to me on just
a buy-in signal that client's going in
that's that full attraction traction
keep in touch so they might have been oh
can I see the CV or oh I'm interested we
might be hiring in a month it's so often
that we're just chasing New Leads
chasing new business you forget about
those people that have given you buying
signals so if you just keep a list of
those they've come back me at some point
again they're on my six weekly scheduled
to call chip away at them and at some
point a lot of the time they then move
over into them
then so I've got tons of business agreed
traction keep in touch
um what about Target have you got a
Target yes Target Client List so that's
the one when I've mapped it out these
are the like 10 15 clients where I'm
like I really want to work with them and
I tell them I want to work with them as
well like in my emails not begging but
I'm like I actually really want to work
with you and this is why like I really
like that you're doing this those Target
client lists in my Approach will come on
to it but they're my like really
targeted email shots or conversations
uh yeah exactly and they're they're like
ones I'm doing a lot of research and
spending a lot of time on and then I
might have like old clients so these are
clients that I might have worked with at
previous companies or work with in the
past but the Love's gone a little bit
and we haven't worked with them in the
last year so they're just slow burners
trying to get them back onto the terms
of business so there's only really four
columns but they build out and oh one
last one if there's any leads I'm
obviously lead chasing but that one I
mentioned to you once all of the leads
is moved from the period of chasing to
okay they must have filled it they've
not come back that goes in my lead no
response column because that's how I
build out right this business they've
been hiring and looking for 10 people in
the last three months they're someone I
really want to Target so again another
BD session in one of my weeks will be
calling through the video response no
response yeah okay because it's so hard
right when you're doing BD a lot of the
time people will say to me I don't know
who to contact exactly well if you've
got this spreadsheet you've already got
five columns now with people that you
can contact and schedule that each week
alongside so many other ways to BD and
it just helps take that mental strain
off a little bit sometimes oh my God
yeah and I wish I'd had a spreadsheet
like that yeah like this because you're
just doing you're then it just makes
what your BD is so much more purposeful
yeah you know what I mean and it's a lot
more focused it's a lot more intentional
and it's just smarter definitely so so
just to round that out then yes just to
wrap up those columns so everyone
understands what those are right so
we've got let's just start from the
right right to the left so just go back
from where we just started Okay so we've
got at the very start then so the very
the very start we've got we just got
leads yeah so that's the so the one we
just said was the leads where they've
not come back okay leads no response and
then we've got what like leads chasing
or active leads uh yeah that's I didn't
even mention that one but you have got
your actively Jason as well that's
another question
active leads and then if we then go oh
clients all clients no love anymore but
I work with them at some point in my
life then you've got
um a buying signal one what was it the
uh yeah so that's the client's
attraction keep in touch list
um and then you've got your terms of
business agreed clients as well then
you've got your dream yeah your target
Client List as well okay cool and
they're the companies that you've known
by getting information that they're you
know hiring a lot they're probably
spending a lot on agency spend and there
would be a good uh customer to get in
with right yeah definitely they took
those boxes okay so then so that's
absolutely fun so that's been fun fed
said that like having a process like
that has been fundamental for you to get
you know acquire those number of clients
that you did and to get the most out of
those clients and to get the most out of
your BD activity yeah yeah because
otherwise back in the day you'd say do
BD power hour and I'm thinking
yeah who am I going to call like and I
know I've got this whole database but
I'm just calling people for the sake of
calling it there's no structure this
structure has honestly changed the game
yeah because you you know who you're
targeting and you've got that
consistency they're going to at least
hear from me once every six weeks yeah
not too much but it's all about the life
approach so let's so I want to go into
like the approach because I think that's
a natural thing but just very quickly on
building the information Nation on this
spreadsheet because that's going to be
fundamental so I think you said you said
earlier about speaking to clients speak
to candidates make sure you know there's
a value exchange or like share things
like whatever like if you're starting a
market how can you do that because you
know if you're calling me and you're
like yeah so you know started a deco
building a desk from scratch like what
what have you got to to give me if
you've got no jobs you're not working
with any customers so how did you how
did you approach getting this
information like why why would these
people give you time particularly
clients who are busy that have things
that need to do so like how you know why
would these people give you time to get
the information that you need yeah
that's a really great question and
that's something I struggled with when I
started I didn't know anything why am I
calling these people because why are
they going to give me anything like
they're not getting anything in return
and the way so if anyone's listening now
and they're just starting a market
it all comes back to this honesty piece
I will call people I see them online and
I say look I'm going to level with you
I've just started out into the market so
that they know I want to be able to
speak with really great candidates and
help them find jobs and I've seen that
you're looking and from what I can see
your skill set looks great I might not
understand all the lingo so you might
have to speak with me in layman's terms
but I'd love to understand a bit more
about you and then talk you through like
how I can help you and go out and find
you a job and you can say I don't have
loads of jobs at the moment but that's a
good thing because I can actually work
with you and go out and try and find
them for you so firstly be really honest
in your approach with them but then what
you can also do you might not have jobs
and I still do this and it gets a very
mixed opinion from people but if I don't
have a job I see that a business is
hiring and I know I've been trying to
get in with them I can't get in with
them there's nothing I can do at the
minute I'm gonna tell them that they're
hiring I'll say to this candidate look I
don't work with this company but I've
actually seen on LinkedIn you're a
regulatory manager this business are
looking for a regulatory manager I think
you could be a good fit have you seen it
no they haven't seen it why don't you
apply directly they're hiring on
LinkedIn because I can't help everybody
I can't work with every single client as
much as I want to and I like to think
that good things come back around so if
they do apply directly and they get the
job who knows maybe one day they'll work
with me or they're putting a good word
for me and so I think it's just you've
got to be really honest but you can you
can always give them something even if
you don't have anything don't start
spinning a lie don't do fake jobs like
none of that works it just gets you in
hot water be honest with them tell them
what you found see if you can help them
how can you leave a good impression even
if you've not got a job for them at that
time and then they'll they'll give you
more information it's just that exchange
really just keep it real yeah keep it
real okay fair enough and then how long
did it take you then to really start
gaining some like traction because that
period can feel tough so like how how
long was it where you you know how long
was it until where you were actually
then you know being able to get in the
room with potential clients hiring
managers did that take long or
yeah I mean I've been doing recruitment
for six years now and I remember when I
went into Recruitment and there was all
these people having success around me
and it just felt like it was never going
to come for me so
I don't want to talk crap on here and
say you're going to get it instantly if
you do all these things because it's a
slog and I think if you come into
recruitment you have to be prepared that
you might get really lucky and have
success very quickly but a lot of the
time it takes time so let's look at
Adecco I've gone in there but I've got
four years prior experience of doing
this so it's a lot easier in a sense
because I know what needs to be done I
know the conversations I need to have so
actually the results came very quickly
but then if we look at that that's
because I've got four years previous
experience if you're coming straight in
and you're doing these things and you're
being honest and you're building up the
database from scratch you've got these
Excel spreadsheets and you've got this
structure I actually think that you will
see success way quicker than if you're
just fingering the air who am I calling
today yeah but I think you have to be
consistent and probably do it for six to
12 months before you start seeing
regular success the more you are
when you do it to begin with the better
because you're gonna learn like the
conversations I had if you could hear
them now those BD chats so bad yeah so
it's probably embarrassing like I'm glad
there's no recordings but I just do you
have any jobs no okay you didn't get
anything else out of those calls such a
waste of time how long did it take to
sign in first client oh I do not I don't
even know who was my first client that's
three months yeah no it was I did a deal
within my first like four weeks
um at Adecco I actually can't even
remember it was in the first four weeks
yeah yeah it was it was yeah I was just
getting back in touch with people that
had relationships with as candidates
um and then they were working at certain
businesses and then yeah okay from there
so let's now talk about the approach
then because like we've spoken about how
you've been smart around how to
basically use information to Advantage
basically and you then organize that in
the way so then when you do uh you know
put time into business development
you're hopefully doing it in places that
can you know give you the outcomes that
you want in a short-term medium term
long term because you've broken it down
in these different sort of buckets so
why don't we why don't we start then
talk to us about the six week approach I
really like that because that sort of
simplifies then where where did that
come from what's the purpose of that you
know who are you putting on that
six-week Cadence on that six week you
know approach and like what why
basically yeah okay so
I was finding it was getting really busy
which is a great position to be in but
then I was working all of these jobs and
letting my business development slide
which is always a juggling and there's
always a balance for us
um how can I stop this happening and I
need to take it back to basics and look
at my day plan look at my organization
and my structure of how I'm splitting up
my days between Business Development and
resourcing so what I did is I looked at
that Excel spreadsheet that we've just
discussed and Outlook is my absolute
best friend as well I utilize my Outlook
massively so what I do is my outlook's
all um I'm such a visual learner yes all
color-coded
um and so I do my day plan and I'll say
right for this business development what
I'm going to do is week one is terms of
business clients agreed I'm going to get
in contact with them and I'm going to
dedicate one or two hours per day I'll
make it all the way through that list
week two is going to be the next so on
so forth but then alongside that I would
also have easier Business Development
activities because a lot of those are
effort their conversations so if we're
looking at mail shots there I actually
find a lot of success from male shots
but that's only been within the last one
two years because that's been a lot more
um focused as well so back in the day we
would have a database loads and loads of
clients and I just say I've got a great
qar manager ping out to everyone you
might get lucky if you get a response
but that's not a great way of doing
things so my advice to people would be
in the success that I've seen
is localize mail shots so if I've got a
candidate in Manchester I'm contacting
manchester-based companies saying I've
got this candidate if I've got a
candidate with wound care experience I'm
contacting all my wound care clients and
the way that I know where my clients are
are hot lists call lists whatever you
might call them in your agency and it's
great if you're starting from scratch if
you're not and you've already got an
existing database start doing this as
soon as I add a client
let's say oh I'm an orthopedic client
they're going in my Orthopedic call list
if I add a candidate and they're in
Manchester they're going in my
Manchester candidate call list so that
soon as then I've got a job in
Manchester I can go and call my quality
managers in Manchester it's just all
about segmenting it to make your life as
easy as possible so Business Development
it will be yeah sending out those male
shots that are really really tailored
and those responses have honestly now
gone through the roads right yeah yeah
so just as as much it's much easier to
send a mail shot to everyone and yeah
for the best so yeah segmentation make
sure the people that are receiving that
it makes sense yeah have to ask what's
going in the smell shot yeah a lot of
people send mail shots like what what's
your like non-negotiables on on the mail
shots not answer you want because it's
different each time depending on who it
is but I'll give you one that I sent
um I sent last week actually it was a
bit of a scary title but you've got to
be clickbait right
so I actually did have someone that was
a May redundant in quality okay so my
title was redundancy in QA and they're
probably thinking holy like
everyone else
um so it was legit but obviously yeah
yeah okay so this person was made
redundant so I'd literally just say like
hi hi whatever the name is yeah hi Jane
um I'm working with this candidate
they're literally they're based in
Manchester they're about 20 minutes from
your site because it would be really
local unfortunately they've been married
made redundant their experience includes
one two three bullet points
um appreciate I've emailed you at the
blue but said I do all I can to help
this candidate that I've worked with for
the last two years is there anything
that you could you think they could see
at the moment more than happy to send a
CV on request I will never send a CV I
will never send a profile unless engaged
by the client one gdpr you just cannot
do it with candidates now it's really
recruitment don't do it but two
that means the client needs to come back
to you they don't have the goal of that
is to start a conversation yeah you've
got to start a conversation and get them
on the phone so that's a really generic
one um and I have done more tailored
ones for my target Client List as well
which we we can dive into as well okay
so mail shorts is one of your core ways
of approach then yeah definitely that is
easier I appreciation rather than being
on the phone what else we've got going
on then
PD
um what other parts are fundamental to
your approach that
you feel has been effective in terms of
helping you move those clients into each
each area yeah I think his consistency
in approach though we've got that six
week period but also being really
tailored in your approach for your
Target clients so um I think I mentioned
to you before about this
um subject line so I've just said about
redundancy in QA but let's put yourself
in that client's shoes and they are
honestly getting hundreds of approaches
a day why are they going to open your
message why are they going to come back
to you I've been desperate to get this
client back on I wish I could say I've
got them right now I don't I opened them
up for my last business and they're a
huge account and then I moved on and I
because I was working contract they were
always higher in perm even though I
opened them up I've not I didn't get any
love so I've not got those relationships
and I've been trying and trying to get
in contact with this person and it's
really important in recruitment you've
got to find a fine line between you're
getting in touch and you're not being a
pest yeah so hand got in touch and I
sent this subject line this person who's
in HR that I need to build the
relationship with she's been on holiday
and I saw that she was eating chips by
the beach and I've been trying to call
her and every time I call her she's
either on leave or like can't speak yeah
so I literally just put holiday chips
and quality and I just think like those
little subject lines are so different to
recruitment or Partnerships she's
probably thinking why is someone like
putting chips in the title I'm actually
really using this three-prong approach
now because it's had such a good success
rate and then I would just bring that
into the email oh hi every time I've
called you you've been on holiday or I'm
seeing on LinkedIn you're eating chips
yeah yeah or again it's just
personalization so it takes more time
but these Target client lists on
LinkedIn
um there's another client where I met
with about four years ago not been back
in touch and then I saw they did a
podcast so I thought right I'm gonna be
different I'm gonna listen to this
podcast and there was a transcript so I
took some information from it and I said
I'd listen to your podcast I really
loved XYZ I said I met you four years
ago and I've not managed to get back in
touch with you since but the direction
you're going and I really want to be
part of I know you've hired three people
this year through an agency what's it
going to take for us to get back in and
have that conversation with you I got
meeting booked let's go let's go I was
like that I always celebrate those small
wins everyone everyone what did that
response look like it's like oh like um
thanks listen to the podcast or like I
hope you enjoyed the podcast yeah yeah
and let's be honest it was CEO and I put
um podcast feedback and then whatever
the title was they're gonna want their
ego rubbed and see what's the feedback I
want to I want to click that so they
clicked it open just said hi Amy really
good to hear from you and thanks for the
feedback it was a great um great talk
um no recruitment this year but let's
put some time in for the back end of the
year and I said cool I'll send you an
invite it's accepted the invite whether
he's going to turn up that's programming
that's it progress exactly move them
along in that spreadsheet life yeah if
it doesn't happen you've got what lead
no response or like things they're
progressing which is the the whole
objective right yeah but you've got to
find that right environment for you
because when I first started in
recruitment it was quite old goal of
that you want fifty dollars on the phone
you want two hours and I think that's
really good when you're starting out to
understand the intensity but you don't
have time then if you're going to hit
those kpis to tailor these types of
messages that actually do get a good
response and don't get me wrong my first
point of call is not email I always try
and call them first these emails are
only in follow-up when I can't reach
them because it's all about different
touch points call then email and connect
on LinkedIn so that you're in your
you're in their face in every Avenue and
so you need to find a business that they
might set you kpis but you have to have
the freedom to be yourself tailor these
messages and try different things yeah
it's not just that one Pronger Pro this
podcast is proudly partnered with
vincere the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20 000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our mission in helping you get the
most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10 of the usage price forever
use a link in the show notes to get your
hands on that let's get back to the
episode that was going to be my next
question like how have you then
Incorporated you know the the phone in
this because it seems very you know
being personalized uh working smart
um you know very um online you know
heavy right so has that been really
pivotal that you're following up at
least trying to get them on the phone
and these things and then all of this
all the stuff that you've spoken about
helps you build trust or helps you stand
out so then when you do get them on the
phone and you're yourself and you're
authentic
you have a better chance yeah yeah
always and this is my advice to my team
as well because I think we've got a few
younger people in the team who you've we
grow up right with emails and texts and
so that's their approach to clients but
you cannot be picking up the phone
getting your personality across and
having those conversations so I know
I've spoken a lot about emails and lists
but I will always always recommend you
call them first leave a voicemail so I'm
going to pop you some information on an
email you then make sure you send them
that email and you'll sound the email
I'm going to collect with you on
LinkedIn and then you do that so there's
three different things there that
they've had from you in the space of an
hour yeah okay I think the natural
progression of this then because I know
we're going deep into BD stuff I know
this yeah this is what I love I feel
like yeah yeah I love it I used to hate
it but now I love it I feel like I found
myself why let's just talk about that
because people will relate to what you
just said I used I hate BD what like
what's changed is obviously part of it
obviously you shared with me a big part
of you know you
um enjoying recruitment again was you
know being environment that encouraged
to be yourself or gave you more autonomy
that's obviously part of it but why why
do you now feel like that yeah so
firstly when you first start you'll be
scared of doing BD yeah it's normal
everyone is I was but also you won't
believe in yourself like self-belief is
huge so I would not I wouldn't even put
myself in the position for Success
because I would think I can't call that
CEO he's going to think why are you
contacting me I can't email them I can't
take time out of their day yes you can
like you are actually trying to do them
a favor so the sooner I realize all
they're going to say is no sometimes
they like very very rarely you'll get
someone that swears at you that's on
them they're having a bad day okay move
on but you do get well you always hear
the word resilience and you do build
that over time the more rejection you
get the more the less you care about it
so firstly if you're starting out in
recruitment I know it's scary just just
get on the phone and do it and you'll
hate it but you have to you have to just
do it and find your flow and then I
think the reason I do enjoy it more is
because that's firstly it has comes with
a bit more success because you're like
oh do you know what I can do this I can
get this right and you see the success
so that's reward Loop but also just
because I'm doing it in my own way I had
no structure when I was doing BD it was
finger in the air do a BD Power Hour oh
my God who am I going to call never only
getting voicemails or getting rejected
but now I pre-plan it I have my Excel
spreadsheet I know what I'm going to say
I know what my selling is going to be
that week and so it's much easier
because I know what I'm going to do and
you'll get better results so just try
and have that structured approach and I
promise you that is going to make your
life easier yeah get that system that
works for you it might not look like
mine but find out what works for you and
go with it so I think what what would
sort of be good to naturally talk about
here then would be you know we've got
this approach we've built our system
like obviously part of
um your success has been that you've
done
um you know work
um repeatedly with customers rather than
all just being like spot business right
yeah so what what's been fundamental
there I feel like sometimes obviously
one you're gonna have to deliver on you
know finding people getting them great
people but also then what has Amy done
to really deliver a great experience
which I know that you care about like
what what are you doing on job
qualification that may be a bit
different
um when you do you know agree terms um
and you start working with these
companies what you're doing that you
feel like has had a real impact in them
going you know what they found us uh Amy
Founders they're a great person but she
also did this and we absolutely loved
that you know what I mean what yeah what
else have you done do you think that's
really impacted you having repeat
clients from repeat business I got so
many thoughts going through my head at
the moment and like so many examples of
when I've done it right but also done it
wrong and lost business and I think well
I've lost business there's been a lot of
learns from that so I'll probably touch
on a few of those points as well
um repeat business first and foremost I
would say one of my clients the other
day they called me with a job and I I
asked them I was like can I ask why why
you're using me again like not in a
shocked way but like it's just good to
know what's working he says when I send
him C these I do an overview of why
they're good but I also say where their
weaknesses might be I think a lot of the
time in sales we want that deal we want
that person to get the job we're like
they're so good because of this this and
this but then it overlooks when they
might they might fall short on a few
things so why not tackle that up front
so I'll say they've there might be a
little bit weak on the personality maybe
a bit too timid for what you need to
test them on that in the interview and
they love that transparency because I'm
really being a partner yeah I'm trying
to sell this candidate I want them to
get the job but equally I really want
them to be the right fit so I'll say
when they might fall short so they can
test them a bit
um also there's job spec calls if
they're not going to give me the time of
day for a job spec call I'm in a
position now I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
work that job and in the past if someone
was like oh can you just send CVS
probably would have done it because I
was early on in my recruitment career I
wanted the deal like I wanted a new
client on but unfortunately you will
realize they're the clients that you're
not going to do the deals with they're
going to be a nightmare to work with so
get a job on someone wants to work with
me and I'm a minimum an hour booking
that call out for and that call you know
all right now I love structure I even
though I've done it for so many years
I've got my list of questions that I'm
asking them so I don't feel sure I don't
forget so we'll talk through what's the
job look like soft skills projects
they're going to be working on all these
things that I can really then paint a
picture of the candidate and get them
excited I don't care about the job
description that's great but it doesn't
tell the picture it does whenever I've
seen a job description I'm not excited
about it I'm excited about what can I
get my tea stuck into but at the end of
that call a lot of the time back in the
day I'd have been like okay brilliant
I'll get your CVS and I'll get you CVS
and we'll catch up then leave it with me
but then how do you know when you're
next going to speak to them have you
locked them down on feedback have you
agreed slas I want this as a partnership
so I'm going to respect you put loads of
time into this and get you CVS but I
need that respect back and I need us to
have agreements of CV feedback catch-up
points and so I can be really open with
the candidate and they have a good
experience I feel like an extension of
my clients when I work with them and I
know how small the medical Market is and
a lot of other markets they need to have
that good rep about Canada experience
and that's what I'm delivering so I will
say at the end of the meeting what works
really well for a lot of my clients is
if we put in a weekly catch-up call 10
15 minutes over teams over the phone
whatever works for you I can then be
really transparent in what the feedback
is from the market whether people are
happy with the salary location anything
we might need to flex on and we can have
that as a touch point that if I don't
hear from you at all I know at that
point I'm getting CV feedback and we're
moving things along hopefully I will
hear from them before and I normally do
but we know when we're catching up is
there and a very good indicator if the
client misses that one time second time
they're not committed you put that job
on the back burner and you email them
and you say I've not managed to catch up
with you we set this in place this is
what we agreed from the outset I really
want to support you and work this job
but I'm sure you can appreciate I need
to work with clients who are ready to go
let me know when you're ready we can
pick this back up it's not being scared
to call your clients out like you are
giving them your time you're good at
what you do you've got to hold them
accountable but you then have to deliver
as well so I think those things have
been really good because then the
clients I'm working with are like okay
she's a partner of mine I gotta treat
her that way we treat them the same and
then they want to work with you again
because you're just honest you do what
you say you're going to do you hold them
accountable as well as them you I think
those are the best that's been that's
been fundamental yeah with me after
after you've done a job spec agree in
The Next Step because then you're not a
recruiter you're a consultant and I
think that's a really massive difference
as you are in the industry a lot more
recruiters are quite transactional you
get a job you place it on to the next
Consultants are you are working with
your clients who get the best results
you sometimes have to have uncomfortable
conversations but they're going to value
and respect that more and come back to
you again when they need help and that's
the big shift
so what what other service level
agreements do you agree do you agree do
you say like typically what my clients
work to is if I send over a CV I'd
expect feedback within 48 Hours yeah is
it what what other things do you agree
with them I wouldn't say I dive too deep
so I would say like if I send a CV I
would hope that we could get feedback in
48 hours typically I would I would give
myself a week I would normally be able
to send CVS within two three days yeah
if I'm sending them quicker I've either
got a candidate already in mind or I've
got lucky because I need to have
detailed conversations with my candidate
so I'll say that to clients because
I think sometimes they want people
straight away and they can get that from
some agencies
but and I'm not saying this at all but
whenever I've seen that they've just
sent a candidate and not had a
conversation so I'll tell them that but
I will say CV feedback within 48 hours
then usually interviews we want to break
down the stages on this speckle so I
would say two stages really if you're
going to do any more you are going to be
falling short of the competition not
many people are doing three even at
senior level so we'd agree the interview
process and then the main thing is agree
in that Weekly catch up getting that in
the diary sending them a calendar invite
they accept it and put that reoccurring
until the job is filled so only those
three things and that's simple that's
simple yeah what I really I don't know
if you agree with this but I feel like
what what that also enables you to do
which a lot of recruiters I feel like
failed to do when they're when they're
not being as much of a consultant is you
then have an opportunity every week to
showcase the work that you're doing yeah
because if you know Amy back in the day
was like yeah I'll get you CVS yeah we
don't speak for five six days because
you haven't been able to uh it's taken a
little while they might be thinking what
the Amy what's she doing what's
she doing right but every week you're
going so look this week I've managed to
speak to this amount of people
um so far actually the feedback on your
brand has actually been really positive
these are some of the reasons why
however you know we mentioned about this
role and I said to you that it might
actually be a bit difficult to get some
of that experience because of the pay
bracket I am getting that sort of
pushback and like do you know what I
mean like you can do have all those
things it's a 10 15 minute call every
week and you're going to be able to
Showcase what you're doing I had that
just this week um we're looking for a
role for one of my key clients at the
moment and they are paying 45 Grand and
it's a really hard location to find
people and I said from that outset it's
going to be really difficult I think
you're gonna have to go away and get
higher salary we've got it up now two
weeks later with that feedback we've got
them four CVS but they haven't got the
experience that they need on the
management piece and I said it is
because of salary people are already on
50 55. we've got 65k now that's a 20K
jump that wouldn't have happened if I
wouldn't have had these touch points and
that approach yeah I love that and do
you think that has then enabled you to
agree better terms yeah definitely
everybody wants cheap at the moment I'm
finding that and there's a lot of people
that can do cheap percentage fees but
then I always hear on the spec calls
they've got a lot of trash and they're
not getting regular updates so that is a
big USP and a sales point that I'll say
look I'm not not the cheapest but this
is what you're going to get from me if
service is what you're after that is
what I pride myself on and I do pride
myself on results but if I won't get you
results you will have like a structure
in place or you will have an
understanding of how you can find people
or what you need to flex on because I
want to fill every job but let's be
honest you can't always because it might
not be the right salary it might not be
the right location or there might just
be another recruiter if it's
multi-agency that's had a head start or
a better candidate at that time that's
okay but what what impress question have
you left that client with why are they
going to come back to you even if you
didn't fill the role and they will if
you've done a really really good process
and experience do you use case studies
yeah oh God yeah all the time how do you
use them well a lot of the time if
there's clients um let me give you an
example in Manchester I had a spec call
a couple of weeks ago and again their
salary was like five to seven k
um not load but five to seven K under
the market yeah and I'm quite lucky in
Manchester as the big hub for me I've
got quite a few clients and I just gave
them an example I said look I'm working
with this person which is pretty local
so a competitor for you they actually
were just hiring for a quality
specialist we filled that within two
weeks and this is why this was the
salary this was the process I said
you're telling me you want somebody on
this date reality is we're gonna really
struggle because you are paying below
this and so it's just really given them
real-time examples and to telling them
more what the Market's doing
I would never give and I really respect
my clients I'm not going to give like
solid competitor information that's an
unfair Advantage for clients but I'll
give them a heads up on this is what the
Market's doing this is what the
candidates are looking for this is an
example from a recent experience in
hiring experience I just had if you
don't follow process you're going to
struggle yeah it's your call
um and they do appreciate it these case
studies that they're like you know have
marketing got their hands on them or
they just have you just put them
together like no a deco I mean if
someone watches this they're not going
to love it but I'm marketing is great
for the wider Adecco but for the small
sections if we want to do something like
that we pretty much need to go out do it
ourselves we'll just make this on camera
or something yeah I've got a canva
account um just I love canva anyway like
from my own personal side so I do a bit
on there we had one Mark I have to give
a shout out to our marketing I did reach
out to them recently because I was over
my head and I needed a pitch deck I
actually lost a bid I put a LinkedIn
post about it so I don't know if you saw
but I had this be CD call he'd been
recommended to me from a client I place
with and this company looked so good I
was like you know when you want to work
with them I was like I want to work this
so bad yeah and we were vibing like we
had such a good Speck call so much
information but you always even at this
level like you have to see right what
did I do wrong and there was a few
things one he wasn't the sole person
that could make the decision there was a
board decision and I'd only met with him
and you didn't know that or didn't know
that didn't know that didn't ask that
question I just assumed my bad like when
you last when you last worked for an
agency who was involved in making that
decision exactly so I slipped up there
like I hold my hands up and two
um I thought we had a really good
experience I sent over our terms I
agreed the next touch point to find out
who he was going to work with I asked
what it would take to decide who'd work
with ask all of that but that person
that got the job they sent over a pitch
deck so they sent over our terms and
this is then how we're going to work
that role so cool right so I I when I
was told and how heartbroken that I
didn't get the job because I'd already
written up like the LinkedIn I was
manifesting I was like this is the job
I'm so excited to be working it then on
the next day and sorry you haven't got
it I was like right where did I go wrong
because I thought we had a good well
firstly great question that you
asked that oh for sure yeah I need to
know like I take new things personally
I'm competitive with myself so where'd I
go wrong and he said look I really like
you but this other this other business
sent over a pitch deck exactly breaking
down who they're going to contact how
they're going to work our role I
presented that to the board versus a
conversation we had and they were like
let's go with this these these people I
said okay I could I maybe I should have
asked for it but I didn't I just said
okay so pitch text what it might have
taken he said yeah I said really
appreciate that so I went to our
marketing team and I was like I lost out
on business because I don't have a pitch
deck I need to sit down with you and
make one and I've now made a pitch deck
so any time if I'm up against another
agency I'm following up and sending that
so that's been a learn for me but it's
now Competitive Edge that I can do I
love that um changing my sales process
I've spoken yeah a few times now but
that is is such a great asset yeah
because why would you not have something
that visually supports like the way that
you work yeah and imagine particularly
in those scenarios where he then had to
go into a board meeting and go well I
met this really great recruiter Amy
schum recommended this is her background
this is what she's going to do and like
they basically just have to rely on his
words exactly and then they're gone and
then I spoke to this other person who's
got similar experience to Amy actually
and then
um I can also show you you know what
they're going to do from the moment that
we saw in terms with them yeah like you
probably would have done the exact same
thing that they did but you could walk
into that meeting with some a visual
asset that he can then use to sort of
get the sign off on that yeah exactly
that's a great tool that you'll now have
which again just it just levels up the
experience before they've even agreed
time with you before they've even
started working with you yeah and I
think it's a big learn for me because it
just goes to show from those negative
experiences and those rejections what
can you learn to improve next time I
really was hoping I was going to get
that and it hurt but I can't dwell on
that I'm like right where did I go wrong
yeah let's go again and you have to have
that mentality you can't dwell on it you
have to just go again and then quick one
what are the headings on that pitch deck
what have you now put into if you didn't
have one before what like what have you
put into it that you think is worthwhile
putting into it yeah it'd be good to get
your feedback on this after as well to
see if I've missed anything so we've got
that overview so I put the client name
and my name
um and then the date that we spoke and
then do a brief spec overview so my
understanding of the role
yeah brief recap then it will be the
process I'd follow so we do
specification call then um candidate
qualifications CV submissions interviews
just that timeline of events yeah then
if they've given me a specific timeline
we knew this person by September I'll
walk it back I'll be like right well you
need to give me interview CV feedback by
June interviews last interviews need to
be this date in July offer this date for
them to start then so it's like you need
to meet these these slas then meet the
team so if there's any other roles they
want to work on it's me and the rest of
the team this is what we do just so
you've got that in there and then I'll
give them how that we will resource so
what platforms that we use to Resource
I've then got a testimonial page with
some LinkedIn highlights or email
feedback that I've got people always
want to buy from people that enjoyed an
experience
um and I think then it's just a page on
our terms as well even though we've got
the terms separately it's nothing major
but it's just a visual I was going to
say if you have a testimonials you've
got to have testimonials that sounds
like a that sounds like a pretty solid
simple yeah overview yeah that's
exciting to start using that that's
you're going to be buzzing when you
start closing people with that oh it
hasn't happened yet but I'm just waiting
actually I had a meeting yesterday and
sent my first time sending the pitch
deck so we'll see you should what you
should what you should consider is
actually
um potentially incorporating that in
your spec call okay yeah because you
could I think that would be a good thing
to do send that over yeah well no then
within that hour
within that hour you could be like right
so for the first 30 minutes I want to go
through the role and then what I'm going
to do is I'm then going to actually go
through you know the process you could
have like half of that pitch tag yeah I
love that that's a good idea like let's
do all the information and then what I'm
going to do is instead of me talking
through everything I find you know
people find it a bit more used to
visually see I'm just going to talk to
you through like if we do sign terms and
I'll start working with you this is what
the process looks like yeah and then
we'll go through that together any
questions you know any hesitation blah
blah blah and then like okay cool well
what I'm gonna do is now I'm going to
follow up with you know what we've gone
through today what I've learned about
the role and also you know my process
yeah I like that that would make that
mint yeah I'm gonna do that that's a
good idea let me know I think that would
be a good little way to use it because
then you're using it during the process
yeah and then when people are visual
Learners I'm a visual learner because it
takes away fitting from like just a chat
do you know what I mean it's like
because then you make it you know
co-branded it's like you put their
company logo in there I've not got that
good idea definitely do that yeah you
just template you just change the
company logo each time yeah with yours
make that that that that's taking that
one for free thanks
um so look let's let's end with then
like you know you saw my post this week
I think you have every right to to be
here like clearly like you've learned a
lot absolutely love your mindset yeah
you've you you're clearly you know
really found your groove your your
building
um you know your brand your Market
um why is it that when I reach out to
you know women 50 of people say I'm not
sure you know you should yeah in the
podcast because you you try to justify I
know why you should be here right and I
was like no you have every right to be
here so just talk to us about you know
your experience and anything that can
Inspire more women listening to this to
you know step into that yeah
confidence and like no I I should be
where I am and I am good and these
things I know and I loved I loved that
post and I was reading through the
comments like oh my God so many women
feel the same yeah why is that I've been
thinking about this and way up like how
am I going to answer that because I
think it's a different experience for a
lot of women
I think there's a lot of men in
recruitment when you look at it's
similar to engineering roles there's a
lot of men it's just very male dominated
and it really lends itself well to men
because
typically by Nature they're more
resilient they ask for what they want
they like got this dominating presence
like it just works well in recruitment
but on the flip side as women by Nature
we are quite caring very
detail-orientated like
we yeah we can bring so much more to the
table as well
and so I just think as women we need to
not be afraid to shout about we're doing
well we're doing really well and we're
okay to share it I think a lot of the
time even growing up it might go back to
when we were younger but it's just like
oh oh you know you've got to be humble
don't don't speak too much about your
successes who don't want people to think
you're you're big-headed
that's always what you get told I I got
told about that a lot I think not from
the immediate family my family are great
they want to build you up they want you
to be successful but yeah and so I just
wouldn't shout about my success as much
and then you just feel like oh I'm not
great I'm not great compared to everyone
else and in recruitment a lot of the
time I think my reason to you was you
said oh you know you've got top Billow
and a Deca and I was like yeah but just
FYI like the villains weren't amazing
like what you've had on your podcast
before I felt inferior because I see all
these huge million pound billers half a
million pound Millers I'm not there yet
and but I personally don't have a desire
to be for me I just want to be working
with clients time and time again
consistently Bill and Bill a decent
amount that gives me a good lifestyle
and work balance as well but I think
women in business in general we need to
be
more vocal about our success willing to
help other people and build people up
and find our voice because you can very
easily be silenced if you're not that
outgoing sometimes in a recruitment
company
um but just don't be afraid to speak up
speak about your successes and help
other women get to where we damn well
should be because we can do it too
um and I think there just needs to be
more more Role Models around there and
well you're doing that doing it yeah
I've put myself out my comfort zone so
hopefully some other women will be uh be
happy to come on for you as well I
appreciate you having me on as well I
was nervous but you put me right yes
Amy thank you so much love your story
love your mindset thank you so much for
joining me okay and thank you thanks so
much